come in here when we're trying to go to
bed and then you just
go and you say
you all better start respecting me are
we clear
yeah britney spears ex-husband kevin
federline is sharing his receipts
posting videos of her arguing with their
two sons jaden james and sean preston
you all need to start treating me like a
woman with worth
i am a woman
okay
be nice to me do you understand
no the former dancer shared two old
videos on instagram wednesday night the
first featuring brett having a word with
the boys at her home this is my house
if i want to come in here and give you
lotion for your face because it is
coarse and all you tell me no it's fine
it's fine no it's not fine
you all better start respecting me are
we clear
yeah then we see brit upset with her
eldest son for not wearing shoes inside
a store and disciplining him by taking
away his phone
have you lost your mind
i do care but i'm shocked as
with you and i don't know what to do and
i'm scared of you because you're weird
because you're going through puberty i
was in shock in the store when i looked
down and jaden how are you so cool about
that your brother being with bear's big
feet size 13 now well he's my brother
and all the more exposed his feet your
blood in an ice cream shop in in in
alaska weather
don't you think that's a little odd no
uh yeah i think your phone should be
gone kevin since deleted both videos but
in the caption he explained why he felt
the need to share i cannot sit back and
let my sons be accused in this way after
what they've been through as much as it
hurts us we've decided as a family to
post these videos that boys took when
they were 11 and 12. this isn't even the
worst of it the lies have to stop i hope
our kids grow up to be better than this
hashtag never fear truth kevin hinted at
those same feelings in his interview
with itv's daphne barack that aired
earlier this week they
started sending me
videos and certain things that they were
like look i'm telling you that this is
happening the boys have decided that
you know
they they're they're not seeing her
right now it's been a few months since
they've actually even seen her and
seemingly in response to that interview
britt posted her side of the story in a
lengthy post that's also been deleted
the singer goes into detail about her
strained relationship with her kids
expressing her disappointment in kevin
for making all this public she also
writes that she used to see sean and
jaden twice a week but that's soon
reduced to just once a week yeah i know
that teenagers are just hard to deal
with at that age but come on there's
being rude then there's being hateful
they would visit me walk in the door go
straight to their room and lock the door
the latest in all this back and forth
between brittany and her ex well it
could get legal britt's lawyer matthew
rosengart released a statement thursday
he says kevin posting those videos is a
legal issue specifically cyber
harassment and cyber bullying we urge mr
federline to act with a measure of grace
and decency and to cease from publicly
discussing private matters which
benefits no one et has reached out to
kevin for comment
[Music]
you